so apparently frank lloyd wright  jokingly said a good building should let  the rain lincoln a little because he  understood what a wonderful experience  it is to experience the weather from a  dry safe comforts of your home  introducing water as a experiential  element  it can really elevate your designs  there's a couple ways you can do this  you can introduce a roof with deep eaves  where people can sit inside near an open  window  and  watch the landscape and listen to the  rain and smell the rain in this case the  overhang forms a boundary between the  wet and the dry areas  a porch is also a wonderful thing  it can serve as an extension of the  living room it animates the building it  animates the streetscape and it's a  place where your family can get together  to experience a summer storm